شكرا لميسون اهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه ونخصص معظمها لتغطيه التطورات
في السودان نبدا بالعناوين
السعوديه تواصل اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من
السودان سفينه جديده تصل جده على متنها
20020 راكبا معظمهم امريكيون
قصف جوي لمقاتلات الجيش السوداني يستهدف
تمركزات للدعم السريع بمحيط مطار الخرطوم
والقوات ترد بالمضادات
جنوب السودان يتحدث عن موافقه البرهان
وحميتي على هدنه لاسبوع والجيش يؤكد الا
تفوضى مع قوه الدعم السريع
في اخبارنا ايضا
تتاهب لهجوم مضاد ضد القوات الروسيه
وموسكو تعلن اتخاذ خطوات لتسريع انتاج
الاسلحه
[موسيقى]
في اليوم الثامن عشر من المواجهات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لا صوت
يعلو فوق صوت الرصاص انفجارات عده دوت في
محيط مطار الخرطوم حيث استهدفت مقاتلات
الجيش قوات الدعم السريع وردت تلك القوات
بالمضادات الارضيه وفيما وصلت اعداد
القتلى الى 550 شخصا بحسب وزاره الصحه
السودانيه توقعت الجامعه العربيه الوصول
لوقف اطلاق نار خلال اسبوع او اسبوعين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه عن عدد من عن عدد
من تم اجلائهم من السودان حتى الان والذي
بلغ خمسه الاف وسته مئه وتسعه وعشرين شخصا
من رعايه 100 جنسيه واثنتين وقالت
الخارجيه السعوديه ان عدد المواطنين الذين
تم اجلائهم من السودان بلغ 239 اخرهم مساء
الثلاثاء علمتني سفينه جلاله الملك الرياض
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
فتواجد حاليا على متن سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض وهي الرحله الخامسه عشر منذ بدا
عمليات الاجلال من ميناء بورتسودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحري سوف ناخذكم في
جوله خاصه لشاشه العربيه كما نشاهد الان
بدات عمليات الانزال بعد ان وصلت هذه
السفينه من ميناء بورت سودان في رحله
استغرقت قرابه العشره الساعات من ميناء
بورت سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده على متن هذه السفينه 220 راكبا من
خمسه جنسيات
نتحدث عن 91 من الجنسيه الامريكيه و14
مواطن السعودي وثلاثه كنديين واثنان من
جنوب السودان وواحد من الجنسيه السودانيه
ايضا نتحدث انه اعداد كبيره تصل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده منذ بدء عمليات
الاجلاء خلال الايام الماضيه نتحدث عن
ارقام اجم تتجاوز الخمسه الاف
مواطن اجنبي من مئه جنسيه تم اجلائهم من
ميناء بورتسودان الى جده عبر قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه او حتى الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه وكذلك الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
اعداد كبيره من الرعايه يتوافدون يوما بعد
يوم وتزداد الاعداد بشكل ملحوظ مع عمليه
مع كل عمليه اجلاء ايضا ومتوقع وصول سفينه
مدنيه تجاريه سعوديه على متنها اعداد
تلامس 2000 شخص يوم
ظهر يوم غدا
اذا بريطانيا تطلب من رعاياها في السودان
التوجه لبورتسودان لاجلائهم غدا ومن
المتوقع ان تغادر رحله اضافيه السودان في
الثالث من مايو ايار كما قالت الحكومه
البريطانيه في بيان لها بخصوص الرعايه
البريطانيه الذين لا يزالون يرغبون في
مغادره البلاد نائب المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه في افاده صحفيه اليوم
من القنصليه الامريكيه في مدينه جده
السعوديه استقبلت وقدمت خدماتها لاكثر من
350 شخصا من المواطنين الامريكيين
والحاصلين على اقامات دائمه بالولايات
المتحده الذين فروا من السودان في ظل
الاوضاع العسكريه الراهنه التي تشهدها
البلاد
لازم اشتغل يعني في في الظروف دي بالذات
لازم اشتغل عشان اقدر
السلع ذاته في زياده يعني اي حاجه زايده
لازم انا اشتغل
باجي بشتغل زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقف لانه
البلد ما امنه ما بقدر طبعا
ما بيعرف بينا فيه ولا ما في ما حيصدق
لازم تخاطر بنفسه يحاول يشتغل القواد ما
حبابه والخوف ما منه فايده
[موسيقى]
اظهرت صور ومستهدفه طيران الجيش السوداني
لاهداف وتمركزات تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
نتابع يلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في المقابل قالت قوه الدعم السريع في بيان
لها انها اسقطت الطائره من طراز ميغ تابعه
للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم وذكرت قوته دعم
السريعه انها تصدت لغارات عده شنها الجيش
السوداني صباح اليوم على مناطق سكنيه في
الخرطوم
هذا ونشر حساب المتخصص بالخرائط الحربيه
خريطه لمنطقه المعارك في الخرطوم حيث تظهر
الخريطه سيطره واضحه للجيش في اغلب مناطق
العاصمه خصوصا من جهه الشمال اما في وسط
العاصمه الخرطومه فتظهر الخريطه حاله
تجاذب بين الجيش والدعم السريع في وقت
تتوسع سيطره قوات الدعم باتجاه جنوب
العاصمه
في السودان الاشتباكات تتواصل رغم الهدن
وضع انساني كارثي وتحذيرات دوليه من
الاسواق اما شرطه السودانيه باتت امام تحد
اخر سببه التفلت الامني في البلاد اذ نظمت
حملات لمحاربه الجريمه بهدف بسط هيبه
الدوله وسياده حكم القانون الحملات شملت
في يومها الاول مناطق الفتاح العضليين
وسوق الدخينات وسوق الكلاكله مرورا بابو
ادم والعزوزاب وسوق الشجره بينما نظمت
الحمله في يومها الثاني في شارع الشهيد
ابراهيم شمس الدين ومنطقه السوق الشعبي
بالخرطوم وابو حمامه والمرافق الحيويه اما
حمله اليوم الثالث شملت مناطق امتداد شارع
الرميله مرورا بصك العمله ومخازن السكر
والمنطقه الصناعيه
الحملات حققت اهدافها المطلوبه بمشاركه
القوات المسلحه لتامين الاسواق والمناطق
التجاريه الهامه والمرافق الحيويه
الى ذلك اعلنت وزاره خارجيه جنوب السودان
ان رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوه الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وفقا من حيث
المبدا على هدنه لمده سبعه ايام تبدا يوم
الخميس المقبل وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان
البرهان
خلال اتصال هاتفي مع رئيس جنوب السودان
سلفا كير ميرديت على تسميه ممثلين عنهما
للمشاركه في محادثات سلام تعقد في مكان من
اختيارهما
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم يوسف عزت المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوه الدعم السريعه اهلا بك
معنا استاذ يوسف مره جديده في تغطيه
العربيه المستمره للاحداث في السودان هل
يمكن ان تؤكدوا لنا هذا الكلام الذي
نقلناه عن وزاره خارجيه جنوب السودان
الاتفاق من حيث المبدا على هدنه لمده سبعه
ايام تبدا من يوم الخميس المقبل
حقيقه الامر
اعلنت وزاره وزاره خارجيه جنوب السودان
نحن
علاقتنا بجنوب السودان علاقه وطيبه هي
دوله كانت جنوب جزء مننا ونحترم قيادتها
سلفاكير الرئيس لكن الاعلان عن عن موافقه
سابق لهوانا نحن تلقينا اتصال وتلقينا
رساله مكتوبه من جنوب السودان وقلنا لهم
اذا لم يستطع البرهان
الوفاء بسته هدن وما زلنا نحن اليوم نعيش
هدنه معلنه
والطيران يخطف المدنيين ويخطف مواقعنا لم
يتم الالتزام بكل هذه الهدن فمن نستغرق
لاوانه
النقب الحدودنا لمده اسبوع تبدا بعد نهايه
هذه الهدنه الاختبار الحقيقي هو الالتزام
بهذه الهدنه وقد اعلن غايه قوات الدعم
السريع في اكثر انه مستعد حتى لو وقف
اطلاق النار اذا كان البرهان يسيطر على
الجيش اذا كان يستطيع الوفاه بتعهدات هو
يعلم تعهدات امام المجتمع الدولي لاكثر من
سته هوجن ولم يلتزموا بواحده طيران كل
الشعب السوداني كل العالم يرى ان الطيران
يقصف مواقع مواقعنا ويدمر مستشفيات ويدمر
احياء ويضرب بيوت هذه فوضى
ولكن يعني قبل ان ندخل في موضوع الاتهامات
المتبادله اذا انت الان تنفي موافقه قوات
الدعم السريعه على هدنه اسبوع او وقف
اطلاق نار لاسبوع ابتداء من اليوم الخميس
المقبل نعم نعم لم نوافق على هدنه لمده
اسبوع نحن اشترطنا اذا نجح البرهان في هذه
الهدنه يمكننا الحديث عن تمجيد هنا او
يمكننا الحديث عن عن حتى وقف اطلاق النار
ولكنكم كنتم توافقون على الهدن المتتاليه
ولو لثلاثه ايام ما الذي يمنع الان من
الموافقه على تمديد هدنه لسبعه ايام نحن
نواه
جميعا السودان ليس منطقه معزوله عن العالم
ليست منطقه خاليه من المراقبه ليست خاليه
من الستلايت الشعب السوداني يرى الجيش ليس
لديه مشاعل الارض نحن نسيطر على مواقعنا
ولا نتحرك منها ولا نواجه بهجوم اخر هجوم
للجيش كان قبل يومين في منطقه الصالحه وفي
متحركه قدم من كردفان وتم التصدي لو
هزيمته نحن نسيطر على مداخل الخرطوم كلها
لا ليس هنا كحركه مشاه في الخرطوم كل الذي
يحدث هو قصف مدفعي وطيران يقوم ويخصفه
ويسبب اضرار كل الشعب السوداني يراه
منقوله على السوشيال ميديا فهذا من الذي
يخرج الهدنه ولكن الجيش يتهمكم باتخاذ بعض
الاماكن بالناس الذين فيها دروعا بشريه
باحتلال مستشفيات باجبار ناس على اخلاق
منازلهم بالسيطره على مواقع معينه وهو
الجيش الحامي الحمى القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه ويريد ان يقوم بدوره بالتالي اليس
كذلك يا اخي يا اخي هذا حديث حديث اصبح
مكررا اصبح غير غير لا يمكن تصديقه الجيش
اتهمنا بكل شيء اتهمنا اننا دخلنا مستشفى
الخرطوم وحولناها لسكنه عسكريه وادخلنا
السلاح اثبت الاطباء وبالاتصالات في
صفحاتهم انهم ما قالوا يمارسون اعمالهم
الطبيعيه في مستشفى الخرطوم لجاوا لفريات
ان انا استيطرنا على مستشفى نحن نسيطر على
شرق النيل من محله من كبري المنشيه حتى
البطانه ليس فيها اي جيش ومستشفى شرق
النيل يعالج فيه الجرح العمليات يعالج فيه
جر من الجيش والدعم السريع بالامس وصف
لتطبير غصهم
للمستشفى اعلن ان الدعم السريع يسيطر
عليها هذه كلها يعني تضليل للراي العام
محاوله الانتصارات وهميه الاداره لعمليات
انا اسال الجيش واسال الذين يقومون عليه
تريدون اغناء من هل تريدون اغناع الشعب
السوداني الذي يرى الذي نقوم بحمايته نحن
فتحنا الاسواق في ام درمان وحمينا
ها فتحي حله وقوف
فتحنا في كوبر كل الاسواق تحت حمايه الدعم
السريع كل المواطنين يعرفون ذلك ينظرون
الى ذلك على ان نحن لا نتخذ
نا موجودين في ارتكازات في كل الكباري
المؤديه منه الى الخرطوم موجودين
يعني انت تعرف بياناته اكثر منا ويقول
بانه هو المسيطر على البلاد ولو انه الوضع
يعني في بعض مناطق الخرطوم انتم لا تزالون
تسيطرون عليها الا ان الوضع مستقر وهو
الذي لا يزال يمسك بزمام الامور انعدا
عن الاحاديث سيد حميدتي بالامس فسرت على
انه
فيها التراجع بسبب حديثه عن ما سماه خيانه
ضباط له وعن اعداد يعني من القتلى والجرحى
في صفوفه
يمكنك الاتصال عشوائيا على اي رقم في
الخرطوم اسال المواطنين من الذي موجود في
في الشارع من الذي موجود في الارتكازات من
الذي يحميهم من الذي يطارد
اللصوص من الذي يحمل البيوت التي تركها
اصحابها وذهبوا الى الولايات نحن نقوم
بدورنا او موجودين على الارض الجيش يضرب
عشوائيا لكن عمليا على الارض هنالك ثلاثه
واربع جيوب موجوده للجيش معروفه لا داعي
لاضرب رقم لا اعرفه نحن ونتحدث الى صحفيين
ونحن يعني قناه لنا كثير من الناس على
الارض ويقولون بوضوح وليس فقط الى صحفيين
الى محللين سياسيين الى ضباط الى لواءات
سابقين في الجيش ويتحدثون عن عمليات نهب
وسلب ترتكبها قوات الدعم السريع عن احتلال
منازل عن قنص عن فوضى في عدد من المناطق
وليس فقط في المناطق الاساسيه التي نتحدث
عنها يوميا يا اخي نحن ندعو الصحفيين
الذين يتحدثون وندعي كمراتكم ان ناخذهم في
جوله على كل المناطق التي نستطيع عليها
وهي مناطق واسعه وغدون هذا ونستطيع الان
تامين حياه اي صحفي يريد ان يرى بكاميرته
ويسجل
الواقع نحن نسمع هذه الدعايه في الاعلام
لكن نحن نعيش وسط الناس وموجودين ولدينا
اللي جانا احياء نتعامل معها هنالك تشكيل
لجان احيا في معظم احياء الخرطوم تتعامل
مع
اسمح لي بس انتم غير قادرين على حمايه
انفسكم لان تريدون حمايه صحفيين يعني هذا
كلام مرسل
كم عدد القتلى من قوات الدعم السريع وعدد
الجرحى وعدد من انشق عنكم وعاد الى صفوف
الجيش وعدد من اسر
دعني اقول لك شيء اليوم الاول للعمليات
نعم الطيران ضرب الناس وهم غير مسلحين في
معسكر كالوري في معسكر سوبا هذا لانه كانت
مفاجاه ولكن نحن استعدنا زمام المبادره لا
اقول لك ليس لدينا شهداء نعم لدينا شهداء
ولكن اسال الجيش كم متحرك متحرك
متحرك متحرك كردفان متحرك الشماليه كلها
هزمت هنا وضباطه معنا القائد محمد حمدان
حين اتكلم عن خيانه
الضباط لا يتحدث عن ضباط الدعم السريع
الذين هم من صلب الدعم السريع يتحدث عن
ضباط الجيش المنتدبين الى الدعم السريع
والمكلفين بقياده القوات
بعد صوت اصدار البرهان لقراره بالغاء
الانتداب الى الدعم السري
هذا شيء طبيعي ان يعود الضباط للجيش
باعتبارا لهم يتبعون للجيش اصلا اصلا لا
يدعون لنا نحن منتدبين في اطار القوات
الدعم السريع كانت جزء من الجيش
تجاوزناه ونحن الان في الاسبوع الثالث
لدينا قياده ميدانيه لدينا شعبه عمليات
لدينا طريقه عملنا استطعنا الصمود
يستطيعنا ان نصد هجمات طيران نستطيع
بناء على كل ذلك لماذا لا توافقون على
هدنه من سبعه ايام كما تحدثت خارجيه جنوب
السودان ما الذي يمنع يا اخي نحن نتعامل
مع قوه
وافقنا على هدى ام بواسطه امريكا بواسطه
السعوديه لم يتم الالتزام على بالهدنه
ليس للقول من خلق الهدنه لا يمكن ان
تطلبني ان اوافق على هدنه وانت تعلم من
الهدنه ولا
بعضهم البعض بخرق الهدنه ولكن الان هل
انتم مستعدون لارسال
الممثل الذي عين من اجل البدء بمفاوضات
ولو كانت فنيه ولو سمها ما شئت
نحن
الان ندرس عده نغ
در الجنوب السودان لدينا مبادره المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه ابدينا ملاحظات
وابدينا اراءنا ومن حيث المبدا نرى انها
يمكن ان تعود الى الى حل
ما زلنا ندرس عدد من المبادرات الاخرى
مادنا على تواصل مع الجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الافريقي وكل المنظمات مازلنا
نتواصل معلومه من المتحده نحن نريد هودنا
او ايقاف نار يوقف الحرف السوداني الى
الابد هذه
الحرب ليست فدائيه هذه الحرب فيها خطاب لا
يتفق
السودان يوافقون على هدنه من سبعه ايام
اولا ومن ثم تتكثف الاتصالات للبدء
بالجلوس على طاوله التفاوض ومن ثم يحصل
وقت اطلاق النار نحن لا نرفض الهدى نحن
الان في هدنه
الجيش بهذه الهدنه فاذا شخص بغض النظر عن
الالتزام من عدمه الان ما مشكله هناك هدنه
معروضه عليكم ما مشكلتكم حتى لو لم يلتزم
ما مشكلتكم في تجديد الهدنه والجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات تتحدثون عن ملاحظات ما هي
ملاحظاتكم هذه
نحن من جنوب السودان
روي الهدنه ونحن اصلا المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه ما هي ملاحظاتكم انس جنوب
السودان الان لو تكرمت
ملاحظاتنا
اطرح الهدنه التزمنا التزمنا بالهدنه التي
اقترحوها لمده ثلاثه ايام جددناها مره
اخرى لمده ثلاثه ايام ونحن هذه اللحظه
نعيش يهودنا وما زالت طائرات
فيجب
نا ان يستطيع البرهان للجلوس معه وتوقيع
وقته اطلاق النار او توقيع هدنه ممتده
بمراقبه عليه ان يثبت
خلال انه
[موسيقى]
راجع الحدث
راجع التلفزيون الحدث العربيه الحدث هو
قال
يلتزم بوفيه الاغنار ولا علمه
بالموافقه الامريكيه يبدو ان الجيش
نحن هناك جهه اخرى سيطرت على الجيش هي
التي تحرك نعود هنا الى اتهامات سيطره
ضباط اسلاميين على الجيش
هذا اتهامكم الدائم ولكن لا يبدو انه
سودانيين يعني
بمختلف اطيافهم
يصدقون مثل هذا الكلام بل شرائح كبيره
منهم تقف الى جانب قواتهم المسلحه وباتت
تنظر الى قوات الدعم السريعه على انها
ميليشيات متفلته لا هذا راي لا يوجد قياس
راي للشعب السوداني الشعب السوداني مزاجه
العام نحن نتواصل مع كل الشعب السوداني
موجودين نحنا من رحمه الشعب السوداني
نعرف ونعرف تفكير الشعب السوداني في في
عمليه السلم هؤلاء الذين يتحدثون باسم
الشعب السوداني لا علاقه لهم معروفون
لديهم انتماءاتهم والسياسيه معروفون لديهم
جزء نظرتهم للجيش لانه يحمي مصالحهم هذه
هذه هذه الفئه لا تمثل الشعب السوداني
الشعب السوداني لم يستطيع احد حتى الان
قياس رايه نحن نعيش وسط الشعب السوداني
موجودين مع الشعب السوداني في الخرطوم
ساحلنا خروجه الشعب السوداني للولايات من
اراد ان يذهب
وقت حكم شعب السوداني يقف مع من لم يعد
بعد ولا نريد الشعب السودان ايضا طرف مؤيد
الدعم السريع وطرد للجيش هذا انقسام
سيفودي يوم كبير في الشعب السوداني
لو سمحت
بس ملاحظه اخرى او او اثنتين على يعني
المبادره المقدمه الان من السعوديه
والولايات المتحده
ما هي ملاحظاتكم الاخرى قلت لي التزام
البرهان فقط
بالهدنه ماذا ايضا
هذه
المظاهرات التي طرحتها امريكا مع السعوديه
ارسلنا لهم ردا مكتوبا تعطينا ايجابيه مع
هذه المبادره ومازلنا نراهن على انها
تستطيع اذا اذا اذا استطاع التوسيع المنبر
تستطيع ان توقف الحرب ولكن
ايضا ليست في اطلاق النار مرتبط بغضايا
سياسيه مرتبط بمصالح
السوداني مرتبط بشل هذه العصابه مره واحده
والى الابد ان تؤثر في تعطيل مسار السودان
الديمقراطي الذي عطلته 30 سنه ان تساهم في
في في في نهب خيرات الشعب السوداني
الوصول الى حل شامل حتى بما فيها القضايا
السياسيه وليس فقط وقفه اطلاق النار نعم
نعم هذه ستبدا اي مفاوضات ستبدا كمرحله
الاولى وتنطلق الى معالجه المشكله
السوداني كلهم هذه قضيه الحرب التي ندخلها
الان او التي نواجهها الان هي ليست حرب
عسكريه باختلاف شخصي بين قائدين او بين
قوات هذه الحرب لها جذور سياسيه لها اطراف
سياسيه دعمتها وعبدت لها وتقوده لابد ان
يكون هنالك حل سياسي لكل لصالح كل الشعب
السوداني
من الاطراف الذين تتواصلون معهم عندما
قلتم بانه هذه هي ملاحظاتنا
نعم هنالك دراسه لتلك الملاحظات وهنالك
ردود وهنالك تشجيع على ان هنالك لانجاح
المبادره وما زال الحوار مستمر متى يمكن
ان نسمع شيئا من هذا القبيل الاجابه واضحه
التزاما واضحا كم اعطيتموهم مهله وقت مثلا
لكي يلتزم الطرف الاخر بوقف القتال من اجل
ان توافقوا على هدنه جديده مطوله
هذه الهدنه مدتها 72 ساعه اليوم نحن في
اليوم الثاني تبقى يوم الغداء ولم يلتزم
بها الطرف الثاني ولا ثانيه واحده وهذه
الهدنه ما زالت مستمره وما زالت قواتنا في
ارتكازاتها لم تحرك اليه واحده من مكان
الى مكان نحن ننزل الامس ننزل التزام قبل
قبلها كانت فتنه تمديدها لم نحرك اي اليه
الا في اطار الخدمات العاديه لم نهاجم اي
اي قوات مسلحه ولا نهاجم اي موقع غير
المواقع التي نسيطر عليها نحن ما زلنا
ملتزمين وعلى الطرف الثاني ان يوقف ضرب
الطيران يعني لا يوجد شيء اخر غير الطيران
هو الذي يهدد حياه المواطنين لا ليس للجيش
مشعل الارض شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم يوسف
عزت المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم
السريع
الى ذلك قال السفير دفع الله الحاج مبعوث
رئيس المجلس السياده السوداني ان الجيش
السوداني يتعاطى مع الهدنه على اساس انها
هدنه انسانيه نافيا ان يكون هناك اي تفاوض
مع قوات الدعم السريع
مفهومنا الان فيما يتعلق بالهدنه هي هدنه
انسانيه
ليست هنالك ليس هنالك حديث عن
اي اتفاق ولا تفاوض مباشر مع المليشيا
المتمرده نعم اقول لك نحن
سندعو
الجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الافريقي
للاطلاع بدور فيما يتعلق بهذه الهدنه
والدول التي بادرت بها وهي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ونامل ان يكون للجامعه العربيه ثقلا ووزنا
وخاصه ان الاخ الامين العام للجامعه
العربيه قد عبر عن مشاعر
مؤيده للشرعيه في السودان منذ اليوم الاول
في هذا الاثناء وانا اتحدث معكم صدر قرار
من الجامعه العربيه
نص القرار على
التاكيد على الشرعيه في السودان وهي شرعيه
القوات المسلحه كمؤسسه وطنيه مسؤوله من
حمايه امن واستقرار السودان
القرار نص ايضا على وطالب باخلاء قوات
الدعم السريع للمستشفيات التي تحتلها وعدم
الارتكاز فيها وعدم
اتخاذ العاملين في المجال الطبي دروعا
بشريه
من الخرطوم لواء ركن دكتور محمد خليل
الصائم استاذ العلاقات الدوليه والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك معنا سياده اللواء
استمعت الى سيد يوسف عزت في مقابلته معنا
قبل قليل يعني هو يقول انه الجيش لا يزال
يقصف ولا يلتزم باي هدنه وبالتالي لا
نوافق على هدنه من سبعه ايام تبدا الخميس
كما قالت جنوب السودان كيف تعلق
المعلومات حقيقه
التحيه لكم وللمشاهدين الكرام المعلومات
حقيقه شحيحه لان التيار الكهربائي
ينقطع ويرجع مره اخرى
نعم
هنالك عدم التزام بالهدنه من انا في
اعتقادي من الجانبين لكن يسمع صوت
الطائرات من فتره لاخرى
ويسمع صوت مال مضادات الارضيه ايضا
وغير ذلك يصنع عدد من الطلقات حتى لو كان
الطيران غير محلق في سماء الخرطوم نعم
هنالك خرق من الجانبين لهذه الغده ولكن
كيف نفسر عدم التزام الجيش بهذه الهدنه
هذا تساؤل قوات الدعم السريع كما قال لنا
يوسف
انه هنالك خرق للهدمه هنالك خرق للهدنه من
الجانبين
انا لا ادري من الذي بدا لانه الذي يبدا
سوف يرد عليه الاخر
بس هو يتحدث عن عدم وجود دموشات للجيش في
الخرطوم عن قصف طيران فقط وعن سيطره شبه
كامله لقوات الدعم السريع على العاصمه
انه هنالك عدم سيطره لكن انا زي ما ذكرتها
قبل كده هنالك انتشار كثير جدا لقوات
الدعم السريعه منذ البدايه في الاحياء
السكنيه في المستشفيات في المدارس في كافه
قطاعات القطاعات المدنيه داخل الولايه
الخرطوم حسب ما ورد لين لدينا ولكن
القوات المسلحه الان ظهرت عدد من
الفيديوهات ما هي تمشط في مناطق
بحري في مناطق الخرطوم جنوب الخرطوم في
عدد من المناطق هي تمشط
واستطاعت ان يعني
معظم معسكرات الدعم السريعه في اركانه
موجوده في منطقه الخرطوم تمام بس كلما طال
الوقت وكانه يعني تصبح مقوله بانه جيش لا
يستطيع الحسم بسبب وجود هؤلاء في احياء
سكنيه يعني تصبح روايه مشكوك فيها بعض
الشيء ما الذي يؤخر الجيش في الحسم في بعض
المنشات على الاقل
الذي يؤخر وجود المدنيين في معظم هذه
المناطق بكثافه عاليه الذين خرجوا من
السودان عدد بسيط جدا جدا من سته سبعه
مليون سكان العاصمه القوميه المتواجدون في
العاصمه القوميه وناس كثر في عدد من
الاحياء مختصه بالسكان
يصعب معها التعامل معه
عربات ذات الدفع الرباعي المتواجده في
شوارع الخرطوم حتى بالقياده العامه بالقصر
بالمطار
القياده العامه هنالك كروه فر
والقصر اساسا هم كانوا متواجدين فيهم حتى
المطار هم كانوا متواجدين وهم وجهزوا من
القوات المسلحه كانوا كانوا يحرسون
القياده العامه يحرسون يحرسون المطار
السوري يحرسون
الاذاعه والتلفزيون يحرسون القصر الجمهوري
القوات الدعم السريعه كانت من القوات
المسلحه
وهي مسيطره على هذه المناطق حتى
المسكنيه الموجوده في حول ولايه الخرطوم
هو كانوا متواجدين فيها في زمن السلم قبل
بدايه فرض الصرع شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور على
وجودك معنا اللواء الركن دكتور محمد خليل
الصائم استاذ العلاقات الدوليه والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه تحياتي لك
هدد هدن متتاليه في السودان كلها باءت
بالفشل ولم تحقق الاهداف المرجوه سواء
بالتوصل لوقف دائم لاعمال العنف او فتح
ممرات انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي في السودان
ليتم خرقها باستمرار وسط تبادل الاتهامات
بالخرق بين طرفين نزاح
هدنه وموافقه ثنائيه وعهود بالالتزام ومن
ثم ترحيب دولي سيناريو متطابق تكرر 6 مرات
على مدار اسبوعين في السودان دائما ما
ينتهي بالطريقه ذاتها دون اي نتائج مرجوه
مع تبادل طرفي الصراع الاتهامات بخرقها
اولى المحاولات كانت يوم الثامن عشر من
ابريل لمده 24 ساعه ليتم خرقها باشتباكات
في الخرطوم وهي وليده ساعات اما الثانيه
هدنه قصيره المدى لمده 24 ساعه انتهت قبل
ان تبدا بالطريقه ذاتها التي انتهت فيها
الاولى
هي اول هدنه تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال ايام
عيد الفطر او كما يفترض ذلك انتهت
باشتباكات متفرقه
تمديد للسابقه لمده 72 ساعه في يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسابع والعشرين من
ابريل تمت ببساطه امريكيه لكن الانفجارات
والاشتباكات استمرت خلالهما
واجهت مصاعب قبل تطبيقها حتى فالاشتباكات
كانت تدور جنوبي الخرطوم مع تحليق لسلاح
الجو السوداني ورد مضادات الطائرات من
قوات الدعم السريع
خروق كانت بشكل اساسي في نقاط حساسه مثل
محيط القياده العامه في الخرطوم والقصر
الرئاسي بالاضافه الى اندرمان وبحري
واقليم دارفور
هدى لا تبصر النور لم تكن اي منها مفتاحا
لفتح باب المفاوضات ووقف القتال في البلاد
ولم تنجح اي منها حتى في السماح بفتح
ممرات انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي باوضاعهم
المترديه وعمر العربيه
تحركنا من يوم الارضي من الخرطوم فكان
المعساه يعني صعبه جدا
ويتحركنا عدد احنا 28
والاولاد يعني ما عندهم عشيره وخليناهم
الان ومتحركين احنا طلعنا من تحت الادانات
من تحت الضرب يعني
طلعنا من الاجوبه بتاع التوتر والضرب لحد
ما وصلنا حلفه
قالت المتحدثه باسم مكتب المفوض السامي
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
ان اكثر من 100 الف لاجئ عبروا من السودان
الى دول المجاوره هربا من الصراع بينما
نزح مئات الالاف بسبب العنف داخل البلاد
هربا من شبح الموت والدمار لجا اكثر من
100 الف سوداني الى دول مجاوره
سيدفعهم 700 الف اخرون وذلك بحسب توقع
الامم المتحده اما داخليا فتخطى عدد
النازحين
334 الف سوداني توجه اغلبه من الخرطوم
مركز الحرب الدائره الى القرى والولايات
المجاوره جنوب السودان وتشاد ومصر ابرز
وجهات اللاجئين بحكم الحدود المشتركه
الحدود المصريه التي استقبلت اكثر من 15
الف لاجئ سوداني بات معبر قسط الاشكيت
البري القريب من مدينه حلفا السودانيه
المعبر المفضل للاجئين السودانيين
المتجهين الى مصر وذلك بسبب انعدام
الخدمات في الجانب السوداني من الخيار
الاخر معبر ارجيه بالاضافه الى وجود
القنصليه المصريه التي تصدر تاشيرات دخول
المواطنين من الرجال السودانيين من سن 16
عاما وحتى 50 عاما
فاستقبلت حتى الان اكثر من عشرين الف لاجئ
سوداني اغلبهم من اقليم دارفور وهو نفس
عدد اللاجئين تقريبا الذين فروا الى جنوب
السودان معظمهم من السودانيين الذين
يعيشون بالحزام الفاصل بين الجارتين
بالاضافه الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه لاجئ
اتجهوا الى اثيوبيا عبر معبر الجلابات في
ولايه القضارف العدد الاقل كان الى
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
1500 لاجئ نظرا لكون الحدود بين البلدين
مغلقه
من اقليم دارفور ينضم الينا صحفي صالح ابو
علامه اهلا بك معنا استاذ صالح كيف هو
الوضع في اقليم دارفور هذه الساعات
اعمل وضع سيدر فور تسوده المبادرات
الاهليه منذ اندلاع المعارك واندلاع
الاقتتال في معظم ولايات السودان والعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
تدخلت عدد من المبادرات الاهليه في اقليم
دارفور البعض النجاح في ان يهدئ الموقف
ويجنب ولايات عديده الصدام يجنب ولايات
عديده الحرب مثل ما حدث في شرق دارفور
وايضا بصوره اقل في شمال دارفور لكن في
غرب دارفور كما نتابع اداره هنالك معارك
كبيره تحولت الى صراعات اهليه
لقيادات الاهليه ليله البارحه وقعت وثيقه
للمصالحات وثيقه تضمنت سبع بنود تحدثت عن
الاقتتال تحدثت ايضا عن فتح المسارات
الامنه فتح الطرقات داخل الاسواق فتح
الطريق المؤدي الى تشاد حتى
من اراد ان يلجا الى
يلجا ومن اراد ان يتعالج من ان يدخل الى
الحدود التجاديه
لكي يكون بامان ايضا يذهب الى هناك اليوم
هنالك عمل في غرب دارفور تقوم به ايضا
الوساطه من القبائل المحايده الوساطه التي
ساقت ساقت هذه الوثيقه تقوم
بعمليه انزال الوثيقه على ارض الواقع حتى
تنفذ البنود هنالك اتفاق ايضا بان تنزل
قوات الدعم السريع
وقوات الاحتياط المركزي التابعه للشرطه
يوم غد الى الاسواق لفتح الاسواق لفتح
الطرقات والجميع يتوافق على هذا الامر بان
صباحا هذه القوات المكونه من الدعم السريع
والشرطه حتى تعيد الامور تدريجيا الى
نصابها كيف يمكن ان نفرق بين انعكاس لما
يحدث في الخرطوم صالح كيف يمكن ان نفرق
بين ما هو انعكاس لما يحدث في الخرطوم وما
هو يعني
قبلي بالمعنى المتعارف عليه في دارفور في
العلاقه بين هذه القبائل كخلاف
نعم ما حدث في دارفور هو
انعدام للامن نعلم تماما بان الدعم السريع
والجيش والشرطه
كان هذه القوات مكونه لتعمل على حفظ
المواطنين حفظ ارواح المواطنين حتى لا تقع
احتكاكات بين الرعاه حتى لا تقع احتكاكات
بين المزارعين وبين المواطنين فيما بعضهم
البعض حتى الدعم السريع هو سريعه الانتشار
يعني تنتشر بسرعه
تلحق الجريمه بسرعه لكن عندما حصل
الخلاف بين الدعم السريع والجيش انفرط عقد
الامن هنا في دارفور واصبحت مناطق عديده
عرضه للسلب والنهب ايضا تحول الصراع الى
صراع قبلي في جو انعدام الامن وعدم وجود
من يسيطر على ارض الواقع حتى مثلا في غرب
دارفور لم نلمس اي
حركه للجهاز التنفيذي اول السلطات الرسميه
نعلم تماما بان الشرطه تم تدمير مقراتها
تماما وتم السلب اسلحه الشرطه وتم سلب
سياراتها وتم تدمير مراكزها تماما
فهذا هذه هذا الغياب للاجهزه الرسميه حول
هذا الصراع الى صراع قبلي ودارفور منطقه
هشه ومنطقه اعتادت كثيرا على الحروب وعلى
الخلافات القبليه نعم هو سنتابع معك غدا
ماذا يحصل عندما تنتشر مجددا هذه الاجهزه
لكي نعرف كيف سينعكس ذلك على الارض شكرا
جزيلا
نعم انا هنا انا
انا هنا في في جنوب دارفور نغطي ايضا
الاحداث في جنوب دارفور ونعم في جنوب
دارفور والان نسمع اطلاق للعيون الناريه
في المنطقه التي يتمركز تتمركز فيها قوات
الدعم السريع هنا في نياله في جنوب ديرفور
اطلاق لعير الناريه كانت تسمع يعني قليله
لكن الان هنالك اطلاق اكثر للعيره الناريه
في الاتجاه التي الذي تتمركز فيه قوات
الدعم السريع ربما مطارده للمتفلتين تعهدت
ايضا قوات الدعم السريع بان تطارد
المتفلدين المجرمين هنا في جنوب دارفور
لكن لم يتبين لنا حتى الان ما هو مصدر
اطلاق
الرصاص وربما صوت للمدافع نسمعه الان
شكرا جزيلا لك الصحه في صالح ابو علامه من
اقليم فرصه نتابع طبعا ذلك معك اولا باول
لعله يعني ليس لعله نقول للاسف انه ربما
يكون تجدد للاشتباكات ولكن سنرصد ذلك اكثر
ان كانت هذه التهدئه هناك ستصمد او لا في
ساعتنا المقبله شكرا جزيلا لك للان اظهر
مقطع فيديو متداول عمليات سرق
ونهب في سوق مدينه ام درمان عمليه سرقه
ونهب في السوق نتابع
في ذمه الله يا جماعه في ذمه الله
في ذمه الله
الحراميه
حراميه ما عنده دكان يمشي عليه
قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض ان الوضع
الانساني في السودان مقلق وانه يتوجب على
جيش سوداني وقوات الدعم السريع السماح
بفتح ممرات لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
للاهالي
مازلنا قلقين للغايه من الوضع الانساني في
السودان والذي يتدهور بسرعه والعنف الذي
ينتشر بسرعه على طرفي النزاع فتح ممر
انساني للسماح لوكالات الاغاثه بتقديم
المساعده ودعم السودانيين والعاملين في
القطاع الصحي للوصول الى المشافي وتلقي
امدادات الدواء الضروريه
كشف تقرير لوزاره الصحه السودانيه تسجيل
ست اصابات جديده بولايه الخرطوم وحاله
وفاه واحده بولايه وسط دارفور ليقترب بذلك
عدد الاصابات التراكميه من 5000 حاله
اصابه و550 حاله وفاه في جميع انحاء
البلاد واوضح التقرير ان الهدوء ساد في
كافه الولايات عاد ولايتي الخرطوم ووسط
دارفور مازال هناك حالات اصابات ووفيات
نتيجه الحرب القائمه
في محاوله لتخفيف اعباء القتال الداخلي
بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الذي
يدور في السودان منذ اكثر من اسبوعين
يخاطر مستشفى خاص في ام درمان بفتح ابوابه
لخدمه النساء الحوامل واجراء ولاده دون
مقابل مادي وفي ظل ظروف امنيه وانسانيه
توصف بالكارثيه
تردي المؤسسات الصحيه
[موسيقى]
يرافق استمرار القتال في السودان
لكن مستشفى خاصا في ام درمان
ينجح بفتح ابوابه لخدمه النساء الحوامل
مجانا
في ظل نادى من شبه كامل للامن
وارتفاع اثمان المستلزمات في السوق
السوداء
اكثر من عشره اضعاف السعر الحقيقي
320 عمليه ولاده قيصريه اجراها منذ اندلاع
القتال
فيما تقول نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان
اكثر من خمسين مستشفى بالخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل
وتحذيراته من انهيار القطع الصحي تتواصل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات